you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I am going to play against the Beast
it's been a little over a month since I
played against computer for impossible'
and I'm just noticing that there's a
little there's a new graphic there for
the beast
a little chip with the four I guess all
right so this is a 15-5 game a little
bit more gas on the clock some more
cushion five seconds instead of the
usual two what to do lets you foresee
form see what the beast comes up with
he's six
hmm alrighty well I guess preparing
Bishop b4 huh Knight c3 nimzo-indian
land
ah let's just start with Knight to f3
see five mmm in a way I feel like I
shouldn't have played night to have
three because of this move hmm okay we
are tending towards a a Benoni where a
computer is very difficult to be that's
my experience at least when we enter a
benoni gives me some serious problems
alrighty well I think I'm gonna go with
d5 here and there is even b5 there
bloomenfeld gambit I believe I don't
think the computer plays that but anyhow
I think the best here is d5 so let's do
it
grab some space okay and d6 well I know
my best spot here best spot for the
Queen Knight is c3 no reason to delay
with that and I'm working with a space
advantage well I don't want to take with
the night let's grab with the pot some
space and now what g6 okay so I played a
blitz game before where I opted for a
bit of a positional setup I think I'd
like to do that here and it kicks off
with h3 Bishop f4 III instead of E for
let's so let's let's start with this
move
I'm prepared to me tonight h5 with
Bishop h2 now and also this kills any
Bishop g4 idea trading now and often an
unproductive minor piece on the black
end voids the light square bishop for
Knight exchange III it is this is my
idea figures a computer would still do
this all right let's put to use my idea
with h3 all right Knight a six where are
you going next
well my decision here is between no I
don't think I have much of a decision I
think Bishop e2 is best going to d3 runs
into navy for stuff I think it's best on
e2 I don't want to go to c4 because I
want to keep that square open for my
knight one day this here is a target d6
so looking to converge on that pond I
think is a good idea let's get another
move in there there should be two it is
sneaky computer then I striking at b2
directly and indirectly hmm
all right I have to be a bit careful I
don't want to go to c2 because of night
B form Bishop f5 how do I defend this
also to be one's no good I don't have
very many options it's probably Queen d2
huh yeah I guess it's Queen to d2 hmm
boy this is surprisingly are I already
feel like it's tough because like if I
go to if I go to d2 I could forget about
pivoting on d2 and getting into c4 and
if I try to stay off of d2 its Queen c2
then there's the move Bishop f5
threatening Knight B form
and he's ready to hop into either c2 or
d3
yeah for a second I was thinking at some
point I could meet Bishop f5 with e4 but
that's not true because there's Bishop
takes Knight and then Bishop takes pawn
can't rely upon my knight as a defender
of an e4 pawn Wow
I already uh slightly off with how I
play the opening Bishop e2 is that not
precise should I have gone with Knight
d2 to meet Queen b6 with Knight c4 huh
maybe maybe this is the move Queen to c1
yeah maybe that is the move feels like I
could be coming under some heavy fire
thou Queen c1 Bishop f5 I think I need
to play a three but then then there
feels like there's ideas connected with
c4 Knight c5 into b3 or d3 but on c4 I
could maybe get away with staking the
pond with the bishop or maybe even
hunting it down with the night I'm gonna
give this a go it doesn't it already
feels a little bit uncomfortable dying
and after all that it's going for a pawn
grab unbelievable alright alright
computer oh so that was the idea just
night before straight away black is
prepared to give up the dark square
Bishop in order to hunt down the d5 pawn
so greedy
unbelievably greedy this is a valuable
Bishop does the computer not know that I
feel like stock fish would smash this
computer if it goes for a life like this
there's no way but yeah that's that's
what's being lined up here how else to
say cuz a3 there's no way they're nice
just gonna come back and I can take the
knight and then grab on d5 maybe I'm
okay with that and I'll try to show
compensation hmm yeah let's do it
go ahead oh you don't want it you don't
want that
well maybe now I could just hang out to
my d5 pawn rook to d1 hmm well I would
be getting this pawn back hang on for a
moment no but I just give him a boo on a
three Bishop takes Knight pawn takes and
on Knight takes pawn
I have rook d1 and if the knight moves I
get d6 and if the knight is defended I
have c4 and then I get d6 let's get him
out of here find a new home unbelievably
greedy unbelievably greedy all right wow
what a pawn grabber
all right rook to d1 that's a valuable
bishop can I show that that bishop his
absence is a problem for black look at
these holes on f6 and h-60 this is
something you'd never see a human do
never not a well informed team black
player
okay well I'm rook to d1 maybe Queen to
b3 looking at Knight c3 man actually I
mean what's wrong with giving this
Knight a boot first just so he's no
longer hiding up any squares here c3
because I feel rook d1 Queen b3
hmm no that's not working is it
maybe rook d1 Queen b3 rook b1 there's
even Knight takes pawn rook takes Queen
Knight takes Bishop with check and then
getting my queen I should probably just
give him a kick right now and then play
rook to d1 house black defending that
pawn anyhow get out of my house there
already and now wrecked a d1 yeah where
else is he gonna go let's do it
94 computer chess ah brother okay gotta
get rid of this guy how do we do this
Bishop to d3 Knight f6 I can also try
Knight to d2 threatening the knight both
nights I wouldn't mind seeing an OPS
color Bishop ending I still feel like I
could track this pawn down to be a
little bit careful of Bishop a4 with
tempo and then this this allows rook to
d1 don't you d8 defending d6 I don't
think I have another square for this guy
anyhow let's try Knight here they'd have
six I'm expecting no Oh what do we what
is this repetition I have a drawn hand
maybe 9 F 399 to d2 this will go over
very well for a video this is what is
what the fans want they want to see if
you could pull off a repetition against
the Beast that's what everyone wants to
know can he do that I think I just want
to take the knight and then get back to
f3 and so how is this pawn defended
let's take this Knight and see what it's
all about now am I not able to just get
this pawn finally good grief I can hit
this pawn like a ton of times I must be
winning Knightly for this guy's hit a
ton this guy alright 94 it is show me
computer ok you're given the pawn back
because you're afraid you are afraid of
your dark squares I guess I'm gonna have
to take right now it's my night getting
stranded somehow my computer has me
edge on edge what about this rook takes
pawn pins and then there's even Knight
to f6
I'd like a knight exchange opposite
collar bishops then I could I feel like
I'm in a better position let's make a
move you got three minutes so now I
could do this
there's no bishop move wits check huh
and then here let's give that a go
balance material I'm still not playing
with this guy oh man heesu feels a bit
out of play and he is he feels out of
play because he is out of play how can I
get my Queen on g7 how can I get my
bishop on this diagonal easily I don't
see and let's see that happening
Queen c3 Bishop hears no I can't he's
pinned Queen c3 - watch out for back
rank mates I need to move my bishop
that's on h2 let's start with this okay
now probably Bishop f4 Bishop h6 let's
try this
okay Bishop h6 hmm Bishop h6 Queen here
suppose I start with Queen e5 hmm yeah I
don't want to be too quick to pull my
Bishop off of this dog you know let's
play Queen e5 can she rely upon that
square for a bit let's try it
132 Wow
okay so look there is prepared but
Bishop h6 defend have two against any
fancy stuff I guess queen bee two is
lined up figures that's the defense Wow
okay okay huh oh I guess the Queen's are
coming off very soon huh I guess still
go here I don't know queen-to-be - yeah
I don't have anything else but to trade
Queens here sake and then what do I do
poof let's uh let's defend this c4 pawn
Wow hmm now I'm exposing my back rank
rookie h1 stuff but I want to stop f5 Oh
Kai and will try for me somehow
defending against mates maybe I could
try for rip to d6 let's get rook here
still okay I guess I'm not getting mates
food
why oh boy
tough tough tough let's take and how
much time let's try this yeah
my king can get flushed out bishop h3
and rook here computer's having none of
my ideas squashing everything I think I
need my King to help but will he be in
time I guess not
let's try this maybe a perpetual now
when
flushed away with Frick checks
uh yeah Bishop check and then a rook
check I don't have anything yeah this is
gone man
just knew how to defend those dark
squares yep I was going to resign anyhow
it's just trying to understand what I
could have done better there okay
well let's review it without the engine
for a moment man it's amazing how the
computers able to still get away with
that stuff giving up that dark square
bishop Yeah right around here I wonder
what more I could do what's something
better I think it's fine to give that
Knight a kick I mean it was could I have
kept the Queen's on I really wanted to
keep the Queen's own that's the way to
really try to exploit those dark square
weaknesses but rook D to Queen B to just
hmm maybe I could have inserted rook to
be one before I went elsewhere with my
queen there's no way I could be worse
right around here huh and seemed fine
dark square weaknesses but at the same
time black has good pieces aside from
these f6 h6 weaknesses hmm yeah we have
good pieces but
you wonder I don't know just getting a
flight square basically by moving my
bishop and trying to key in on h6 but
everything was just so timely Queen e5
could I done without Queen e5 maybe I
should go in for this right away
Queenie oh okay well my concern this was
my idea I mean I played Queen e5 because
I was fearful of this stuff the check
and then another check and I can't block
keep in mind I'm getting made it on each
one if I do that no I didn't mean to go
all the way back so let's just put this
on once more I was fearful of this check
and I guess I have to do this well I
have a main threat I mean how are they I
was I was black stopping rook takes pawn
and then Queen g7 it shouldn't be a fear
I had this f4 move hmm was Queen e5 just
yeah Queeny five was unnecessary here
I should go right in for this Bishop h6
is threatening Wow on Bishop h6 you know
what the computer would do on Bishop h6
the computer would probably play Queen
here so that the queen is there to
defend g7 you know the Rick doesn't have
to move off of this diagonal no but I
mean I have rook takes here now cuz now
I'm gonna get mated aha
man just barely held together here I
wonder what stock fish will be saying
maybe now's a good time to have a look
it was just barely there defending yeah
tried to weasel in computer is having
none of it could have started in a
different way
lay on here
threatening mate king escapes
threatening mate again well yeah I was
threatening a maid idea here with this
in here about H five stops that idea and
just barely able to escape I'm not there
in time it's my king it's just two if
I'm there one move sooner yeah maybe I
get away with perpetual right around
this point if my King's here already I
have this perpetual check idea but yeah
just to move off hmm
all right well let's have a look at it
with the engine and see what I could
have done better
okay stockfish let's see what I could
have done better here against the pond
grabber the greedy
beast benoni on board Knight h5 Bishop
h2 has a tendency to bring their Queen
out I've noticed in the benoni its Queen
b6 Queen a5 more so this Queen b6 stuff
yeah stock fish is just not a fan of it
rook to be one know what b1 I was
fearful of this oh okay that's
interesting that's interesting rook to
be one I was pointing out in the game
there are these ideas to eliminate the
defender of e4 but keep in mind I'd be
recapturing this case and I'd be on the
Queen and the bishop right now all right
well rook b1 I didn't give much thought
to the other recommendation is Queen to
c1 you can't see it okay did pop up for
a second Queen see one anyhow that's the
move I played the issue is Queen d2 was
that I don't have this Knight move and
that bothered me cuz I want I want to
have this option open so Queens c1 it
was night before I just got on with
councils
Bishop d7 now let's go for a night - D -
mm-hmm I just gave the knight a boot
here it's fine with that but it's an
approaching +2 I ready with Knight - D -
I went here for a reason right
why not follow through with this that
computer rattling my thinking yeah I
stayed off of D - so I could get this
maneuver in and it's hitting with tempo
against the night-night c4 into d6
okay I went with giving the knight a
boot which is still good so let's see
how I could have treated this better
this position better right here rook d1
right away I gave the knight a kick with
upon what was my concern with rook e1
Queen b3 let me see what I see why this
was bad yeah this this wouldn't be well
excuse me this wouldn't be good because
there's Knight takes c3 chop chop they
get the piece back rook here Queen b3
top move is ripped to d3 boy does that
feel awkward very awkward suppose Bishop
to one of these two to challenge my rook
I have 9 to d2
okay well I'd have to work that out
that's kind of tricky it's not a very
harmonious looking for sure
I guess I could come straight over with
the rook I'd I could do without pushing
the pawn I could improve the quality of
one of my pieces that could be how I
attack the knight by getting a piece
involved rook d1 was better now I play
rook to d1 nice there doesn't like it
doesn't like Knight here it's suggesting
Knight to e8 because of the follow up
move Knight to d2 I did play that
and I goes back it's not suggesting I
take the night on h5 that's what I did
still okay with that
what is it suggesting here rip to be one
hmm yeah I guess I could go with rook to
be one get on a half-open file first
okay I took the night right away maybe a
bit too concerned with getting the pawn
back as soon as possible
ninety-four a night takes d6 I know it's
rook takes yeah it's pretty level now
hmm Black has good pieces weak squares
about good pieces even prefers black
slightly I guess I don't have anything
let's just double-check Bishop f4 oh my
goodness I'm winning with Bishop h6 +4
ah man I played Queen e5 and now it's a
drawn evaluation level Bishop h6 Queen
c7 threatening mate but I could I could
kill that idea first with f4 or from
what the computer is saying rook to f1
and then this is an issue ah
Queen e5 why did I do that I mean I know
what I was convincing myself of during
the game with Queen e5 to protect the
dog and although it was that was fuzzy
fuzzy calculation Bishop h6 right away I
had my chance get in there Queen c7 it
says rook f1 and another top move is f4
this scares me son because of this but I
have this move like uh yeah I was
pointing it I have rook takes c6 to
clear the way for Queen
g7 mate ah man just get to each six
sooner threaten me hmm so close so close
Queen c7 f4 and there seems to be not a
good defense here computer points out
rook d3 ah man this isn't a concern
though you take the bishop threatened
mate you take my queen I take yours and
I'm up they come up a piece ah man and
you know why I bet you if I made that
move yeah I mean the computer wouldn't
have had anything it would have to do
something stupid because of all there
wouldn't be anything if I played Bishop
h6 Queen Queen c5 if I would have just
parried this threat and I think I would
have seen it at this point just f4 if
some checks this is no bother this main
threat is there's not a good way to
defend against the main threat Queen e7
again I have this oh man I maintain the
Queen on the board without the Queen on
the board these dark squares the dark
square weaknesses and blacks camp it
just wasn't a way to exploit them oh I
totally did not see I was too um I I
thought I had more time to really take
advantage I saw it as you know these are
permanent weaknesses they're not gonna
go away but I did not see this idea with
rook to d2 and Queen to be to kicking my
queen off this diagonal I saw this kind
of stuff in my Koon have to find a new
spot but I think right or even in the
game I was questioning okay if I play
Queen e5 is this is square that she can
rely upon for a while or at least a move
you know when there was but this really
isn't a good a good improvement for the
Queen so there's definitely adjustment
with my thinking there for sure too
be a bit more decisive with my moves
right around this point and really try
to pounce on these dark squares as soon
as possible
Bishop h6 and yeah I'm just a move away
from realizing yeah I'm completely
winning I'll be up a piece Queen c7 best
choice f4 and it's pointing out rook d3
and then I could just grab the bishop
that's right mate threaten the Queen and
hopefully I would be able to win it from
here I think I'm confident enough with
knowing how to win this position but
yeah and I let the Queen's get off is it
even from here no it's even tipping in
blacks favor with the Queen's off and I
be very surprised if I if the computer
allowed something with it being so
simplified here yeah there just wasn't a
chance from this point on so far that's
the case at least yeah everything is
just in time just double-checking yeah I
got nothing I was going to resign at
that point okay
well interesting game yeah not a good
idea don't uh don't do as the computer
does in this game with giving up the
number one minor piece in the ball game
here that dark square bishop he's
important and there are ways to take
advantage of it but you didn't see me do
that in game but there definitely is a
way it was a way to pounce on those dark
squares Queen e5 and do without Bishop
h6 right away at this point and things
are looking really good for mate threat
on g7
okay close is not good enough as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and
as always I hope you got something out
of it that's all for now take care bye
you